vous savez quelle est l'information du
jour pour le veau aujourd'hui non pas du
tout on attend avec impatience la
surprise bon alors la surprise c'est que
le roux est nominé pour faire partie de
l'émission village préféré des Français
ça vous aspire quoi super
n'a pas encore fait le tour de la
commune levroue 3000 habitants fait
partie des prétendants au titre de
village préféré des Français c'est une
grande surprise et c'est aussi une
grande fierté moi j'y vois le signe de
l'attractivité de Levroux qu'on mène
depuis maintenant plus d'un an et demi
avec tous les acteurs de la cité
levrezen les commerçants les artisans
les chefs d'entreprise les associations
bien sûr et une vraie fierté de
représenter aussi notre région la région
Centre-Val de Loire les votes sont
ouverts depuis ce matin sur le site de
France Télévisions jusqu'au 22 mars
minuit les équipes de l'émission vont
tourner dans les 14 villages candidats
qui vont se lancer dans une campagne de
notoriété
on a mis en place tout un tas de
dispositifs un nouvel office de tourisme
qui sera prêt la discrété un parcours
avec des totems historiques qui va être
installés aussi bientôt donc on sera
pareil pour accueillir les touristes qui
auront vu l'émission et qui je l'espère
auront envie de venir ici à Levroux et
il est retombées sont attendus dès
aujourd'hui en attendant le verdict en
direct au début de l'été depuis Sancerre
village 2021 préférée des Français s'en
sert dans la fréquentation touristique a
Bondy de 35 % la fréquentation a
commencé tout de suite le lendemain
après l'émission et puis tout au long de
l'été avec un pic août et puis dans
l'arrière saison septembre octobre
novembre avec un public qui qui venait
découvrir le village préféré des
Français le Berry en force pour
représenter le centre Val de Loire à
Sancerre on veut y croire on va tous
voté pour le groupe on va tous
contribuer aussi à ce que le roux
accède à la première marche du podium